ça fait des semaines qu'on essaie de la
rencontrer de l'attraper entre deux
réunions ou entre deux vols pour
l'étranger je suis jamais à la maison et
gaignac à la moulza est toujours à la
course à la rencontre les chefs d'État
n'est plus influents j'ai pas d'autres
choix vraiment donc je fais mon meilleur
elle habite Washington mais arrive tout
juste de Berlin où il vient d'accepter
un autre prix au nom de l'homme avec qui
elle partage sa vie depuis 20 ans le
père de ses trois enfants je suis forcée
de le faire à sa place parce que lui il
est en prison en Russie ça fait huit
mois qu'elle ne l'a pas vu son mari
Vladimir karamurza
il est l'un des principaux opposants au
régime de Vladimir Poutine un des
derniers qui était encore en liberté
quand la Russie envahit l'Ukraine le 24
février comment il va
il va aussi bien qu'on le peut dans une
prison en Russie il lit beaucoup elle
est quelqu'un de très très fort à
l'intérieur un homme de conviction un
cinéaste devenu journaliste puis
politicien qui a été des plus grands
combats pour la défense des droits et
des libertés en Russie aux côtés de son
mentor le chef de l'opposition Boris
Nelson assassiné en 2017 à quelques pas
du Kremlin
a souvent interviewé Vladimir caramurza
quand il venait à Moscou dénoncer les
abus du régime et la corruption au péril
de sa vie
ça vous fait pas peur vous êtes un
opposant connu vous savez que vous
pouvez être arrêté à tout moment on
connaît des risques il a survécu à deux
tentatives de meurtre par empoisonnement
mais il a toujours refusé de se taire
quand alexis navalné a été incarcéré il
était dans la rue pour demander sa
libération il y a des millions des gens
dans nos pays qui veulent que la Russie
devienne si on utilise les modes Alexis
Navalny en pays européens normal quand
la Russie envahit l'Ukraine il a osé
déjouer la censure du Kremlin
pour lui être silencieux en face de des
atrocités pareilles c'est de venir
complice vous savez c'est
je sais avec qui je partage ma vie
c'était mon choix aussi donc j'ai un
respect profond pour mon mari et une
admire une admiration profonde pour lui
même si ça veut dire vivre sans lui je
suis un optimiste il a été arrêté le 11
avril accusé de désinformation Chris de
haute trahison il risque une peine de 24
ans en prison je vais continuer à son
travail je vais faire tout pour ce que
ce régime s'écroule le plus vite
possible
pour la section internationale du
prestigieux ou Washington Post qui
publie depuis des années les chroniques
de karamuzza justement pour donner une
voix à l'opposition en Russie
continue malgré les risques de publier
les textes que Vladimir rédigeant prison
et qu'il réussit à envoyer à Christine
tous les mois pour donner leur juste sur
la répression quand on vous dit que
personne en Russie ne s'oppose à la
guerre ne les croyez pas écrivait car
amourza au mois d'octobre en ajoutant
les centres de détention sont remplies
de centaines de personnes qu'on arrache
de la rue je n'ai pas entendu sa voix
depuis le mois d'avril donc à chaque
fois que ça sa voix est entendu parce
qu'il est publié pour moi c'est un
cadeau parce que je l'entends dans ces
dans ces mots je l'entends et ce sont
ces mots qui inspirent gagnants qui la
motive à se battre pour tous ceux que le
Kremlin est Cédric au silence madame
Stanley
[Applaudissements]
internationales mais c'est President des
Nations Unies au Congrès américain ou
son mari avait tissé des liens et où il
a contribué à faire adopter la loi
magnétique qui vise à punir les plus
corrompus et les régimes les plus
criminels du monde c'est un de mes buts
de faire voir de convaincre des leaders
de l'Occident que la pression sur le
régime doit continuer et que
Vladimir Poutine ne peut pas quelqu'un
et la démontré déjà que si l'on cherche
des compromis avec lui il va le voir
comme une faiblesse il va continuer avec
sa politique de d'agression elle a déjà
réussi à convaincre le gouvernement
canadien d'imposer des sanctions contre
les individu qui sont responsables de
l'incarcération son mari c'est-à-dire
les policiers c'est-à-dire les
fonctionnaires c'est à dire à les juges
les oligarques tout ça vous le faites
par amour pour lui ou par amour pour la
Russie je crois qu'il m'a fait militante
parce que Vladimir Poutine détruit deux
pays en même temps
il détruit le crâne
et le détruit la Russie aussi
ben je vais continuer mais elle est
aussi une mère consciente du prix à
payer pour la famille qu'ils ont fondé
et qu'il rêvaient de voir grandir
ensemble ça me brise le coeur parce que
ce temps le régime de Poutine se régime
inhumain qui tue et tue et continue à
tuer il nous a aussi volé ce temps ça
dure depuis des années des années
la première fois qu'on Vladimir a été
empoisonnée
notre fille aînée avait 9 ans maintenant
elle a 16 ans et cette enfer continue et
elle en aura 40 le même âge que son père
quand il sortira de prison si les
condamnés pour haut trahison
[Musique]